this is a big big big topic hey everyone
i'm abby sharp welcome to abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and in part two of this two-part series
i'm gonna be talking about the best
foods and supplements for bloating but
first let me tell you about my sponsor
buildbar so if you are a snack queen or
king like me you've got to try these
bars i mean i've got a whole pantry full
of different snacks in my house but i
always keep these in like every purse
and bag and drawer there are built bars
everywhere for when that snack attack
hits and you know what i always say
unless you stole it from a baby all
foods are zero guilt but i love these
because they actually taste like
chocolate bars rather than like a chalky
protein bar because they're made with
real chocolate and they're packed with
protein which we love so this is my
favorite my favorite my favorite and i
am ready for it if you know you know the
cookie dough chunk mmm
she good get at me there are like little
bundles of cookie dough joy it is such a
pleasure
[Music]
cheers good i might have chalk on my
face but that is a hazard of the job now
these are a low in sugar bar so when i
feel like i need like a really solid
complete snack for post-workout this
chopped up on some oatmeal or like with
some berries and yogurt she's good or
you can mix it into ice cream for like a
little bedtime dessert that is happening
that is happening tonight so if you want
to try these guys out yourself check out
the link in my description and use my
promo code abbysharp15 to get 15 off of
your order and you can pause the screen
or look at the description to check out
my disclaimer including a trigger
warning to those with current or
previous experiences with disordered
eating as always feel free to skip this
video if it's not supportive to your
journey and if you're new here please
don't forget to subscribe to this
channel ring that little bell so that
you never miss out and follow me over on
tick tock and instagram abby's kitchen
okay so if you missed part one i went
over the major causes of bloating so if
you haven't watched that get on it then
come back here now we're going to be
talking about what to do with it but of
course a big reminder first of all that
the cure will ultimately depend on the
cause so it's worth noting that you know
beneficial food or supplement for
somebody that has bloating from
constipation could potentially cause
bloating for somebody with sibo and vice
versa now in some cases the solution is
as simple as removing or limiting a food
as in the case of like a food
intolerance but the thing about
functional digestive nutrition is that
there's rarely a black and white
straight solution it's a lot of trial
and error and it might take a cocktail
of supplements foods or lifestyle
changes to really get relief for you now
it's also worth mentioning that a lot of
remedies out there are not super well
researched so i always recommend working
with your dietitian and doctor to find a
solution that's unique to you i myself
consulted with not one but four of my gi
rd colleagues on this video just to
really get their clinical insight so a
big thank you again to dasha aguilnek
amber gurley caitlyn self and lacie dunn
for all of your help as always i'm
leaving some links to their practices
below for you guys to check them out
with that said let's talk about foods to
beat the bloat food number one as i
mentioned in part one one of the reasons
for bloating can be poor digestive
outputs including having the right
digestive enzymes needed to break down
food we see a ton of digestive enzyme
supplements on the market which i'm
going to speak to more in a minute but
there are also a lot of foods that
naturally contain digestive enzymes to
help break down food into nutrients that
your body can then absorb for example
papaya contains the enzyme papain
pineapple contains bromelain and kiwi
contains actinidin all of which work to
break down protein into amino acids now
kiwi specifically is my anti-bloating
queen as research suggests that while
prunes psyllium and kiwi all help to
reduce constipation only the mighty kiwi
helped to reduce bloating symptoms and
it only took two kiwis a day hail kiwi
now number two is ginger so we love
ginger ginger has prokinetic properties
that helps to stimulate stomach emptying
and digestive motility and it also
contains the proteolytic enzyme
zingibane so it's kind of like a double
threat now i want to note that the
research on ginger has largely been done
on concentrated ginger capsules so you
would likely need to consume a fair bit
of fresh ginger to see the same clinical
impact but if you enjoy ginger and i
love ginger i really don't see the harm
in incorporating it regularly into your
daily diet now food number three is
peppermint peppermint is my personal
favorite and it's something that i
actually use whenever i feel
particularly bloated after a high fodmap
meal because it's an
anti-spasmodic that helps to soothe and
calm the gi tract now concentrated
peppermint oil in particular has been
shown to help treat digestive symptoms
like bloating and abdominal cramping but
having said that it can also exacerbate
heartburn so definitely a big red flag
to avoid it if you have gerd number four
on my list are bitter foods so pretty
much all of the dietitians i spoke to
mentioned using bitter foods like
arugula dandelion grapefruit etc for
helping with bloating episodes bitter
foods like bitter supplements may help
to stimulate the bitter receptors of the
gal bladder pancreas and stomach to help
naturally increase bile flow digestive
enzymes and stomach acids they're also
delicious and in season this time of
year so something to consider just
working into your normal routine if you
like the flavor of them number five are
fennel seeds now not only are they a
good source of fiber but fennel seeds
have antibacterial antifungal and
anti-inflammatory properties which can
help to improve the microbiome to reduce
fermentation that causes gas now the
anti-inflammatory anaphol compound in
fennel seeds also may help to relax the
intestines to allow for better bowel
motility and therefore the release of
gas finally number six are my super
sprinkles aka hemp hearts chia and flax
so you guys know we love hemp hearts in
my house and here's another reason why
so these tiny little sprinkles are
packed with fiber but their nutrition is
quite concentrated so they don't add a
ton of bulk but you're still getting a
lot of benefits they're also low fodmap
at typical portions so they're
appropriate even for sensitive tummies
so this one is really hit and miss and i
don't want to recommend it to the masses
as something to specifically focus on if
you don't know the root cause of your
bloating so on the one hand some studies
have shown that foods rich in probiotics
may be helpful in certain scenarios for
reducing bloating and gas and that
things like sauerkraut miso kimchi and
kefir contain naturally occurring
digestive enzymes like proteases amylase
and lipase so for example one study
found that the lactase enzyme found in
kefir help to improve lactose digestion
in those with lactose intolerance having
said that if your bloating is the result
of an overgrowth or histamine related
you want to be very cautious about
adding bacteria even if it is good
bacteria so this is where we get into
strain specific probiotic
recommendations for treatment which is
hard to manipulate when we're talking
about a fermented food now moving on
what about the oh so overwhelming world
of supplements so like food the right
supplement for your bloating will
strongly depend on the cause but number
one let's first talk about digestive
enzymes if we're dealing with a food
intolerance or a sensitivity to a
specific fodmap food then the best
course of action would be to limit these
foods in your diet and when you can't
limit them to use over-the-counter
digestive enzyme supplements like
lactate or alpha galactosidase aka bino
now these two digestive enzymes are the
best supported enzymes in the literature
for lactose and alpha galactosidase
intolerances respectfully even still
most folks find that taking a supplement
is really just an adjunct therapy to
help with tolerance they don't actually
fix the problem and they also don't
usually provide absolute relief in an
ideal world we would want to get clients
eating as many foods as possible without
having symptoms the best case scenario
is to actually address the root problem
so if it's an overgrowth for example
like sibo if we actually can eradicate
the sibo then there's a good chance we
can start eating a lot of these
intolerant foods again as for other
digestive enzyme products out there
there are admittedly so many options
most of which have limited evidence to
support that doesn't mean that they
don't work and theoretically most should
work so for example we do have a study
on papaya supplements that have found
that it helped to reduce constipation
and bloating and early research suggests
that concentrated doses of the bromelain
enzyme in pineapple can serve as a
digestive aid it's all very promising
but more human research is definitely
needed to confirm these findings and for
us to figure out the optimal clinical
dose we also know that folks with
pancreatic insufficiency are given
prescription-grade digestive enzymes
like different proteases and amylase and
lipase so there is a clinical indication
for them now i've spoken to dozens of my
colleagues who specialize in this area
of practice who have really no skin in
the game when it comes to the incentive
for suggesting enzymes and other
supplements and they all generally agree
that while the research is unfortunately
quite behind their clinical experience
suggests that these supplements often
can help so again it's very important to
work with a dietitian to get a reputable
third party tested product and ideally
to respond to evidence from something
like a gi map or another stool test to
determine what enzymes you might
actually even need if you want to learn
more about enzymes and bloating i wrote
a whole blog post on this topic which
i'm going to link below next let's talk
about oxbile so oxfile is often
recommended as a supplement for folks
who are experiencing severe bloating
after consuming fats with the concern
that they are not producing enough bile
acids to break those fats down this is a
common suggestion specifically with sibo
since one of the purported causes of
sibo is low bile flow so adding bile in
can theoretically help unfortunately
like most things in the digestive world
we got mainly animal research to go on
which doesn't mean that it doesn't help
but we just don't have great evidence
yet it's also possible to create bile
acid diarrhea if you take too much so as
always please make sure that you're
working with a dietitian to determine if
it's even right for you next let's talk
about detain hcl so low stomach acid can
also trigger bloating due to poor
digestion and then fermentation of food
however research suggests that
supplements like betaine hcl may help to
mediate this by helping to create
stomach acid like ox bile it's not
without risk if you don't know the root
cause for your bloating so for example
folks with h pylori may find that
betaine hcl can actually cause h pylori
to go further into the stomach which
ultimately creates a risk of ulceration
so best again to work with your doctor
to rule any of those things out
supplement number four is iberogast now
iberogast is a tincture made up of
ingredients like peppermint chamomile
licorice root and lemon balm that has
been found to be effective in clinical
trials the research suggests it may help
to reduce gas formation regulate muscle
contractions along the digestive tract
and also improve digestive secretions
which can collectively help provide some
relief anecdotally this is a favorite of
mine and i personally use it with pretty
much every meal finally let's talk about
another one of my go-to's fiber
supplements so we talked about
constipation or slow motility as being
one of the potential causes of bloating
in which case a fiber supplement may
help so partially hydrolyzed guar gum
otherwise known as phgg or like a sun
fiber is a prebiotic fiber that has been
shown to improve symptoms of
constipation in individuals with ibs by
boosting bowel frequency without excess
fermentation similarly psyllium fiber is
another great option for improving
constipation and digestion and has been
shown to help improve symptoms of ibs
including bloating however like fiber
from food there's a real goldilocks
effect with fiber here so both too much
or too little can exacerbate bloating so
always work with a dietitian before
starting a fiber supplement and slowly
work your way up in dose now i want to
close this section off by talking
briefly about probiotic supplements like
with probiotic foods the world of
probiotic supplements is strain specific
and highly individualized but it can be
worth getting it right to help heal the
immune system to prevent further
pathogenic overgrowth and dysbiosis when
it comes to the general population two
systematic reviews suggested that
multi-strain probiotic supplements tend
to be more effective at supporting ibs
symptoms compared to single strains
alone so we usually see a combination or
combinations of lactobacillus and
bifidobacterium strains for more
generalized ibs like symptoms but
depending on the cause of your bloating
espeonardi or a spore based probiotic
like megaspore which is a combination of
bacillus strains may be safer options
for folks with bacterial overgrowth
conditions
finally let's close this video off by
talking about lifestyle hacks to reduce
bloating beginning with eating behaviors
how you eat is often just as important
as what you eat when it comes to
bloating focusing on slow chewing
replacing carbonated drinks with regular
water and mindful eating practices can
all help to reduce swallowing too much
air next is vagus nerve stimulation the
vagus nerve is one of the main
components of the parasympathetic
nervous system which oversees digestion
via the brain gut axis now we have
research to suggest that activities that
stimulate this axis like singing humming
laughing deep breathing and gargling
with water can all help to improve
digestion we also know that really any
activity that is stress reducing to you
can help to improve digestion so i
recommend focusing on self-care on those
days where you feel particularly
uncomfortable
i love the nerva app for some really
great digestion related meditations now
third we have movement now i know when
we have really bad abdominal pain from
bloating the last thing we want to go do
is go for like a run on the treadmill we
just want to like curl up in our bed but
research suggests that gentle exercise
like going for a little light walk or
doing some yoga poses that target the
abdominal area can help to get the bowel
moving and release that buildup of gas
and that brings me to my last point
which is massage and pressure so similar
to gentle exercise abdominal massage can
help to relax your stomach muscles and
release that trapped gas while also
helping to stimulate digestion so you
can gently massage your stomach yourself
or even just lay down on your stomach to
help move things along so that was
pretty much as simple as i could make it
to be
if you're following my sibo saga journey
you know that digestion is anything but
simple or clear-cut it is definitely not
black and white and there's apparently
an expensive product that you can buy to
miraculously cure pretty much anything
out there not to mention the fact that
we are so behind on the research just
doesn't make getting effective quality
care very easy unfortunately the gut is
so complex and for most people curing
yourself uploading isn't going to be
fast easy or painless so i strongly
suggest working with a dietitian who
specializes in digestive health to help
you navigate this snake oil filled world
and on that note that is all that i have
for you guys today a big thank you to
bill bar for sponsoring if you like this
video give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with your thoughts on what
you'd like to see me cover next
subscribe to the channel and i'll see
you next time on abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]